foreign
chain Freight Transportation Logistics
was a trillion dollars a year this is
hundreds of thousands millions of loads
of freight that are moving throughout
the United States every year in terms of
source of emissions of greenhouse gas
it's a massive producer
[Music]
foreign
supply chain is roughly broken up into
what we call modes by far the largest
mode is what we call full truckload that
is a round of 400 billion dollar a year
mode in the US and in theory is the most
efficient way to move Freight but about
half of the big trucks you see on the
highway they're only running half full
if half of those trucks are only half
full we burn the same amount of fuel the
same amount of diesel creates same
amount of greenhouse gas to run a truck
half full as we do completely full we're
addressing that we are getting those
trucks full we do algorithmic carpooling
of truckload Freight we've created a
software solution where you can ride
share your Freight it gives a little bit
of data and they say I'm here today
there tomorrow I'm empty I'm a quarter
empty we take that data and we create a
more optimal outcome for that driver and
for that carrier which is just simply
those two basic things the shortest
distance between two points and making
sure the truck is full which also
creates an income earning opportunity
for the driver the driver's been paid to
haul a load that's only half full we can
create a world in which they can have
Dynamic fluid access to Freight and
revenue the ability to kind of say I
want to opt in or opt out if I want to
work a little more I can make a little
bit more as we scale we will
fundamentally bring down the Paradigm of
modes and create even greater efficiency
the problem with these various modes
they are not integrated with one another
they don't share data they don't share
visibility if we could find a way to
share this data then we could create an
entirely new supply chain that is much
much less resource intensive from a
capital standpoint from an
infrastructure standpoint but also from
a carbon standpoint you'd have a world
in which there were no longer any modes
and everything would be placed into the
river and just flows where it needs to
go this is a massive opportunity for for
whether it's greenhouse gas and
sustainability or value and cost for the
U.S supply chain through more data we
have better insights we make better
decision we build more valuable products
change does not typically occur quickly
so I guess my advice to to just people
on the planet Earth is dream bigger have
higher expectations the next wave of
innovators are going to be focused on
neutralizing carbon in doing so they'll
be the beneficiaries of very valuable
businesses that are also doing their
part to save the world
[Music]